Our episodes deal with serious and often-distressing incidents. If you feel at any time you need support, please contact your local crisis center. For suggested phone numbers for confidential support and for a more detailed list of content warnings Please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website In many ancient civilizations the oak tree was considered to be sacred. Some believed that the mighty oak held great healing powers, or could facilitate communication with the gods. Oak trees can live for hundreds of years.
我们的节目涉及严肃且往往令人痛苦的事件。如果您在任何时候感到需要支持，请联系您当地的危机中心。如需获取保密支持的建议电话号码以及更详细的内容警告列表，请查看您应用中或我们网站上本集的节目说明。在许多古代文明中，橡树被认为是神圣的。一些人认为强大的橡树拥有巨大的治愈力量，或者可以促进与神灵的交流。橡树可以活几百年。
It takes many years for them to bear acorns, and thus acorns are often used as a symbol of patience and maturity. With their tall sturdy trunks, deep roots and sprawling branches, today the oak tree continues to be viewed as a symbol of strength, power, stability, and protection. From a young age, Andrew Gossden was fascinated by science. A gifted straight-A student, he effortlessly sawd through school, winning mathematics competitions at a European level. His above-average intellect eventually earned him a place in the United Kingdom's National
它们需要很多年才能结出橡子，因此橡子常被用作耐心和成熟的象征。凭借高大坚固的树干、深扎的根系和伸展的枝桠，如今橡树仍被视为力量、权力、稳定和保护的象征。安德鲁·戈斯登（Andrew Gosden）从小就对科学着迷。作为一名天赋异禀、成绩全优的学生，他在学校里游刃有余，赢得了欧洲级别的数学竞赛。他超常的智力最终使他进入了英国国家天才少年协会，这是一项针对全国前5%顶尖学生的政府计划。当安德鲁读到种在盆里的橡子可以长成微型橡树时，他必须亲自尝试一下。他寻求了父亲凯文（Kevin）的帮助，凯文总是乐于支持安德鲁的好奇心并鼓励他热爱学习。凯文收集了一些丢弃的橡子，父子俩一起把它们种进了盆里。
Association for Gifted and Talented Youth, a government scheme aimed at the country's top 5% of students. When Andrew read that an acorn planted in a tub could grow into a miniature oak tree, he had to try it for himself. He enlisted the help of his father, Kevin, who was always willing to support Andrew's curiosity and encourage his love of learning. Kevin gathered up a few discarded acorns, and together the father and son planted them into tubs
在他们位于英格兰南约克郡博比（Borby）郊区的维多利亚式联排别墅里。现在他们所要做的就是等待。2007年9月14日星期五晚上，凯文·戈斯登和他的妻子格拉尼斯（Glanis）下班回家，看到了典型的场景。学校刚在暑假后开学，这对夫妇的孩子，14岁的安德鲁和17岁的姐姐夏洛特（Charlotte），已经回到了他们熟悉的日常生活中。对安德鲁来说，这意味着利用业余时间做他最喜欢的事情：在家里改造过的地下室玩电子游戏，或者在卧室的半尺寸球台上打斯诺克。
at their Victorian terrace home in Borby, a suburb in England's south Yorkshire region. Now all they had to do was wait. On the evening of Friday, September 14, 2007, Kevin Gossden and his wife, Glanis, both returned home from work to find a typical scene. School had only just returned after summer holidays and the couple's children, 14-year-old Andrew and his 17-year-old sister, Charlotte, had settled back into their familiar routines. For Andrew, this meant using his spare time to do the things he enjoyed most, playing video games in his family's converted cellar, or playing Snooker on the half-sized table in his bedroom.
虽然他在学校里有一小群朋友，但安德鲁是一个害羞的少年，满足于独处。他更喜欢独自待在家里，而不是出去社交，经常可以看到他埋头于一本读得很熟的书里。当安德鲁没有出来打招呼时，他的父母并没有多想。他们以为安德鲁正忙于他的爱好，晚餐准备好时他就会出来。晚餐对戈斯登一家来说总是一个聚在一起交流的特殊时刻。凯文和格拉尼斯开始拆开杂货并准备饭菜。那天晚上，住在附近的家庭牧师兼密友艾伦·默里（Alan Murray）也加入了他们。
Although he had a small group of friends he spent time with at school, Andrew was a shy acquire teen who was content with his own company. He preferred spending time at home alone over going out and socializing and could often be found with his face buried in one of his well-read books. When Andrew didn't surface to say hello, his parents thought nothing of it. They assumed Andrew was busy with one of his hobbies and would come out when dinner was ready. Dinner was always a special time for the Ghost and Family to come together and connect. Kevin and Glenus began unpacking groceries and preparing for the meal. They were being joined that evening by the family's Vicar and close friend, Alan Murray, who lived nearby.
戈斯登一家是圣公会教徒，但凯文和格拉尼斯希望他们的孩子能自己决定宗教信仰，而不是强加给他们。因此，他们从未给孩子们洗礼，直到后来夏洛特和安德鲁都决定不再去教堂。晚上6点，晚餐准备好了。父母叫孩子们出来吃饭。夏洛特很快从房间里出来，但安德鲁那边一点动静也没有。凯文去检查安德鲁的房间。
The Gossden's were Anglican, but Kevin and Glanis wanted their children to make up their own mind about religion, rather than having it forced upon them. Because of this, they never baptized their children, until Gnouw issue when Charlotte and Andrew both made the decision to stop attending church. By 6 p.m., dinner was ready. The parents called out to their children to come and join them. Charlotte quickly emerged from her room, but there wasn't a peep from Andrew. Kevin went to check Andrew's room.
作为少年放学后的日常习惯，他总是把校服外套和领带挂在卧室椅子的靠背上，然后把裤子和衬衫放进洗衣机。那天晚上也不例外。外套和领带在椅子上，其余的校服在洗衣机里。但房子里到处都没有他的踪影。安德鲁是一个会留字条的人，即使他只是去街角的商店。但找不到任何字条。
As part of the teen's post-school routine, he always hung his school blazer and a tie on the back of his bedroom chair, before putting his trousers and shirt in the washing machine. This evening was no different. The blazer and a tie were on the chair, and the rest of Andrew's uniform was in the wash. But there was no sign of him anywhere throughout the house. Andrew was the type of person who left a note, even if he was just ducking to the corner store. But there was no note to be found.
虽然这很奇怪，但安德鲁的父母并没有过度担心。安德鲁有住在附近的朋友。他们以为他去拜访其中一个朋友，忘了时间。安德鲁没有手机，所以他们无法打电话或发短信给他。他过去有过几部手机，但在完全弄丢之前几乎没怎么用过。他有时会很健忘，而且对这些设备根本不感兴趣。他甚至拒绝了父母在他最近生日时送他一部新手机的提议，
Although this was strange, Andrew's parents weren't overly concerned. Andrew had friends who lived nearby. They assumed he'd gone to visit one of them and had lost track of time. Andrew didn't have a mobile phone so they couldn't call or text him. He'd had a couple of phones in the past, but had barely used them before managing to misplace them altogether. He could be quite absent-minded at times and simply wasn't interested in the devices. He'd even rejected his parents' offer of a new one for his recent birthday,
而是要求要一台Xbox游戏机。戈斯登夫妇给安德鲁朋友的家里打了电话，却发现他根本不在他们任何人家里。他们还被告知安德鲁那天根本没去学校。那个周五的早晨开始得和往常一样。安德鲁醒得比平时晚了一点，但还是及时准备好赶上了去学校的巴士。安德鲁就读于麦考利天主教高中（McCauley Catholic High），距离戈斯登家大约四英里，或15分钟的巴士车程。
requesting an Xbox gaming console instead. The Gossden's called the Holmes of Andrew's friends, only to discover that he wasn't with any of them. They were also told that Andrew hadn't been at school that day at all. That Friday morning had started out like any other. Andrew had woken a little later than usual, but it still managed to get ready in time to catch the bus to school. Andrew attended McCauley Catholic High, which was roughly four miles, or a 15-minute bus ride from the Gosden's home.
早上8点05分左右，他向父母告别并离开了家，穿着校服。此后不久，牧师艾伦·默里回忆说，他开车经过戈斯登家对面的一家韦斯特菲尔德公园（Westfield Park）。他经过时看到了穿着校服的安德鲁，但没多想，因为公园是去校车站的捷径。安德鲁的校服在家，但安德鲁本人却不见踪影，戈斯登夫妇不知道该怎么想。
At around 8.05am, he said goodbye to his parents and left the house, dressed in his school uniform. Shortly after this, Vicar Allen Murray recalled driving by a Westfield park which was across the street from the Gossden's home. He'd seen Andrew in his uniform as he passed by but hadn't thought anything of it given that the park provided a shortcut to the school bus stop. With Andrew's uniform at home but no sign of Andrew himself, the Gossden's didn't know what to think.
他们联系了麦考利高中，行政人员证实安德鲁那天缺席了。这完全不符合他的性格。安德鲁的考勤记录是100%。学校甚至给他颁发了证明他表现完美的证书。一名工作人员那天早上曾试图打电话给戈斯登夫妇通知他们安德鲁异常缺席，但没有人接听。事后反思，工作人员意识到他们一定是不小心拨打了登记册上安德鲁名字上方或下方的号码，导致他的家人被排除在消息之外。
They contacted McCauley High, and had administrator confirmed that Andrew had been absent that day. This was entirely out of character. Andrew had a 100% attendance record. The school had even issued him certificates attesting to his flawless turnout. One staff member had tried calling the gozzans that morning to notify them of Andrew's unusual absence, but there hadn't been an answer. On reflection, the staff member realized they must have accidentally dialed the number listed either above or below Andrews on the register, leaving his family out of the
虽然这并不能解释为什么安德鲁的校服在家里，但戈斯登夫妇考虑了他可能在上学途中卷入某种事件的可能性。他们在自家周围搜索，然后开车沿着安德鲁通常上学的路线行驶。到处都没有他的踪影。他们给当地医院打了电话，但没有接收到符合这名少年描述的人。当晚上9点仍然没有安德鲁的消息时，他的家人联系了警察。
loop. Although it didn't explain why Andrews uniform was at home, the Gossden's considered the possibility that he could have been involved in some kind of incident on his way to school. They searched the area surrounding their home before driving the route Andrew typically took to school. There was no sign of him anywhere. They called the local hospitals, but no one fitting the teenager's description had been admitted. When there was still no sign of Andrew by 9pm, his family contacted the police.
戈斯登夫妇非常确定安德鲁没有离家出走。他们形容他是一个可靠、温柔、体贴的年轻人，绝不会故意做任何让他们担心的事情。据戈斯登夫妇说，他们的家庭生活幸福和谐。凯文和格拉尼斯都是言语治疗师。他们的收入让他们过着朴素而舒适的生活，包括去埃及和突尼斯等地的家庭海外度假。据戈斯登夫妇所知，安德鲁没有心理健康问题，
The Gossetons were absolutely certain that Andrew hadn't run away. They described him as a reliable, gentle, and caring young man who would never do anything to intentionally cause them to worry. According to the Gossens, their home life was happy and harmonious. Both Kevin and Golanus worked as speech therapists. Their incomes afforded them a modest yet comfortable lifestyle, which included family holidays abroad to such places as Egypt and Tunisia. As far as the Gossden's knew, Andrew had no mental health issues,
没有经历过欺凌，也没有其他他可能想要逃避的问题。他最近的行为没有任何异常。如果说有什么不同的话，他比平时稍微安静了一些，社交也更少了，但这并不足以引起担忧。安德鲁是一个除非觉得有话要说，否则不会开口的人。凯文最近问过儿子新学年过得怎么样。
didn't experience bullying, and had no other problems he might want to escape from. Nothing in his recent behaviour had been out of the ordinary. If anything, he had been slightly quieter and even less social than usual, but this wasn't exactly cause for concern. Andrew was the type of person who didn't speak unless he felt he had something worthwhile to say. Kevin had recently asked his son how the new school
安德鲁没有任何迹象表明有什么不对劲。如果他因为某种原因觉得不方便和父母说话，他们相信他会向姐姐夏洛特倾诉。戈斯登姐弟关系密切。两人都非常聪明，有望被英国最负盛名的大学录取。两人对音乐的品味也相似，偏爱重金属、摇滚和后硬核乐队，包括活结（Slipknot）、Funeral for a Friend、缪斯（Muse）、伊凡塞斯（Evanescence）和龙之力量（DragonForce）。安德鲁失踪前一天晚上很平常。安德鲁和凯文一起拼图，然后全家人一起吃了晚饭。父子俩
year was going. Andrew gave no indication that anything was a mess. If he didn't feel comfortable speaking to his parents for whatever reason, they were sure he would confide in his sister, Charlotte. The Gossetant siblings had a close bond. Both were highly intelligent and were on track to be accepted into England's most prestigious universities. The pair also shared a similar taste in music, favouring heavy metal, rock and post hardcore bands, including Slippnot, Funeral for a friend, Muse, A vinescence and a dragon force. The evening before Andrew went missing had been unremarkable. Andrew and Kevin had done a puzzle together before the whole family ate dinner together. The father and son
然后洗了碗。之后，安德鲁和母亲看了一些轻松的电视节目。他上床睡觉时表现得很正常，尽管第二天早上醒来时他似乎有点烦躁。虽然这不符合他的性格，但并不值得惊慌。毕竟他是个十几岁的男孩。正如凯文·戈斯登告诉《每日邮报》的那样，如果安德鲁不快乐或患有精神疾病，他隐藏得非常好。安德鲁的银行账户显示，那天早上离开家后，他走到附近的一家
then washed the dishes. Afterwards, Andrew watched some lighthearted television with his mother. He'd been his normal self upon going to bed, although he had seemed slightly irritable upon waking the next morning. While this was out of character, it wasn't cause for alarm. He was a teenage boy after all. As Kevin Gossden told the Daily Mail, if Andrew was unhappy or suffering a mental illness, he did an amazing job of hiding it. Andrew's bank account revealed that after leaving home that morning he walked to a nearby
加油站，并使用自动取款机取出了他储蓄账户中214英镑里的200英镑。戈斯登家的一位邻居有一个对着街道的闭路电视摄像头。当天的录像显示了一些非常不寻常的事情。早上8点30分左右，就在凯文和格拉尼斯去上班后，安德鲁回到了家。几分钟后，他再次出现在街上，不再穿着校服，而是穿着牛仔裤和一件黑色活结乐队T恤。他背着一个黑色的帆布书包，上面装饰着他姐姐帮他缝上去的乐队徽章。安德鲁房间里除了钱包、钥匙和PlayStation Portable（PSP）掌上游戏机外，什么都没少。
petrol station and used the ATM to withdraw 200 of the 214 pounds he had in savings. A neighbour of the Gosset and family had a CCTV camera pointed towards the street. Its footage from that day revealed something highly unusual. At around 8.30am, just after Kevin and Glanas left for work, Andrew returned home. Minutes later, he appeared back on the street no longer wearing his school uniform, but jeans and a black slip-not-band t-shirt. He carried a black canvas satchel adorned with band patches that his sister had helped him so on. Nothing in Andrew's room was missing besides his wallet, keys, and PlayStation Portable
他没有带游戏机的充电器，也没有带套头衫，尽管9月的夜晚气温在下降。对安德鲁的家人来说，这表明他并不打算离开太久，但他逃学并清空银行账户且没有解释的事实让他们感到非常困惑。即使安德鲁离家出走，由于他的年龄，警方立即将他归类为高风险的脆弱失踪人员。
handheld gaming console. He didn't take the console's charger, nor did he take a jumper, despite the temperature dropping in the September evenings. To Andrew's family, this indicated that he didn't intend to be gone for long, but the fact that he ditched school and cleared his bank account without explanation left them completely baffled. Even if Andrew had run away, due to his age, police immediately categorized him as a high-risk vulnerable missing person.
他们将注意力转向内部。尽管他的家人坚称安德鲁是一个快乐、适应良好的少年，但经验丰富的警察知道大多数年轻的离家出走者通常是试图逃避家里的某种情况。他们让戈斯登家的每个成员都接受了采访，看看是否能发现安德鲁受到虐待或忽视的任何迹象。戈斯登夫妇坚称安德鲁与父母有着开放和诚实的关系，他们既不严厉也不专制。凯文和格拉尼斯完全信任他们的孩子，并支持他们对个性和独立的需求。
They focused their attention inwards. Despite his family's insistence that Andrew was a happy, well-adjusted teen, experienced a tort police that most young runaways were typically trying to escape from some kind of situation at home. They sat each member of the Gosden family down for an interview to see if they could uncover any signs that Andrew was being abused or neglected. The Gossetans were adamant that Andrew had an open and honest relationship with his parents, who were neither strict nor controlling. Kevin and Golanus trusted their children implicitly and supported their need for individuality and independence.
虽然警方认真对待安德鲁的失踪，但在英国每年离家出走的约70,000名16岁以下青少年中，80%在24小时内返回。91%在两天内返回。统计数据表明，安德鲁·戈斯登回家可能只是时间问题。位于唐卡斯特（Doncaster）以北85英里的海滨小镇惠特比（Whitby）是戈斯登一家非常喜欢的度假胜地。安德鲁非常喜欢惠特比，并且很了解那个地区。如果他要因为某种原因离开，很有可能就是这个地方。周末，戈斯登夫妇的朋友前往惠特比，在当地搜寻安德鲁的任何踪迹。他们检查了他最喜欢去的地方，询问是否有人见过这个少年。安德鲁身高约5英尺3英寸，身材苗条，留着中等长度的浅棕色头发，遮住了
Although police took Andrews disappearance seriously, of the roughly 70,000 youths under 16 who ran away in the UK each year, 80% returned within 24 hours. 91% returned within two days. 9% returned within two days. Statistics indicated that it would likely be a matter of time before Andrew Gossden returned home. Located 85 miles north of Donkaster, the seaside town of Wittby was a much-loved vacation spot for the Gossden family. Andrew adored Whitby and knew the area well. If he was going to take off for whatever reason, there was a good chance this would be the place. Over the weekend, friends of the Gossden's traveled to Whitby to scour the area for any sign of Andrew. They checked his favourite haunts, asking if anyone had seen the team. They checked his favorite haunts, asking if anyone had seen the teen. Andrew was roughly 5'3'' and of slim build with medium length light brown hair that swept
他的棕色眼睛。最引人注目的是，他戴着高度近视眼镜，左耳失聪，右耳上部有一个双脊，这些独特的特征使他很容易被辨认。周末过去了，唐卡斯特或惠特比都没有安德鲁的消息，他也没有联系家人。戈斯登夫妇想知道安德鲁是否去了伦敦。虽然首都距离这里170英里，但乘火车不到两个小时就能到达。
across his brown eyes. Most notably, he wore strong prescription glasses, was deaf in his left ear, and had a double ridge on his upper right ear, unique traits that made him easily identifiable. The weekend passed with no sightings of Andrew in either Donkaster or Whitby, nor did he make contact with his family. The Gossden's wondered whether Andrew could have gone to London. Although the capital city was 170 miles away, it could be reached by train in just under two hours.
虽然繁华的城市对一个来自郊区的孤独少年来说可能是一个令人生畏的地方，但安德鲁对这个地区并不完全陌生。他的家人在伦敦有朋友和亲戚，包括安德鲁的祖父母。多年来，戈斯登一家多次前往伦敦。安德鲁很了解这座城市，他的家人认为他会觉得独自在城里穿行很自在。虽然这完全不符合他的性格，但他们想知道安德鲁是否可能做出了周五在城里度过的冲动决定。他最近提到对参观大英博物馆的图坦卡蒙展览感兴趣。
While the bustling city could be seen as an intimidating place for a lone shiitine from the suburbs, Andrew wasn't completely new to the area. His family had friends and relatives who lived in London, including Andrew's grandparents. Over the years, the Gossians had travelled to London numerous times. Andrew knew the city well, and his family thought he would feel comfortable navigating his way around alone. Although it would be entirely out of character, they wondered whether Andrew could have made the spontaneous decision to spend the Friday in the city. He'd recently mentioned having an interest in seeing the Tutankhaman exhibition at the British Museum.
也许逃学是一种青春期的叛逆行为，然后他陷入了某种麻烦。当地火车站进行了调查。当周五早上在销售柜台工作的员工受到询问时，她清楚地记得接待过安德鲁。他买了一张去伦敦国王十字车站的单程票，出发时间是上午9点35分。她记得这次互动是因为安德鲁看起来太年轻，不像是独自旅行。但更值得注意的是，他拒绝了她提供的往返票，尽管往返票只贵了大约50英镑。多名乘客那天早上在去伦敦的火车上看到了安德鲁。
Perhaps Ditching School was an act of teenage rebellion and he'd then found himself in some kind of trouble. Inquiries were made with the local train station. When the employee who had been working the sales counter on Friday morning was questioned, she distinctly remembered serving Andrew. He had bought a one-way ticket to London's King's Cross station, departing at 9.35am. She recalled the interaction because Andrew looked young to be traveling alone. But more notably, he had refused her offer of a return trip, even though it only cost around 50 pounds more. Multiple passengers saw Andrew on the train to London that morning.
他的行为没有任何异常。整个旅程中他一直低着头，沉浸在他的PlayStation Portable中。一名乘客回忆说看到安德鲁在国王十字车站下车，但没有人能证明他从那里去了哪里。扫描9月14日国王十字车站闭路电视的任务交给了英国交通警察。从唐卡斯特出发的火车于上午11点20分到达，但在人群中找到安德鲁·戈斯登并非易事。国王十字车站是
There had been nothing unusual about his behaviour. He had kept his head down for the entire journey, absorbed in his PlayStation portable. One passenger recalled seeing Andrew disembark at King's Cross Station, but no one could attest to where he went from there. The task of scanning through CCTV taken from King's Cross station on September 14 was given to the British Transport Police. The train from Donkaster had arrived at 11.20 a.m., but finding Andrew Gosten in the crowd would be no easy feat. King's Cross is one
英国最繁忙的火车站之一，每天约有30万名乘客经过。被指派这项工作的人员无法在人群中找到安德鲁。安德鲁前往国王十字车站的事实是一个重大发现，但这引发了更多问题。暑假期间，安德鲁的父母曾让他选择去伦敦和祖母住在一起，但他拒绝了。那么，为什么现在不经许可就去那里呢？
of the busiest railway stations in the United Kingdom, with approximately 300,000 passengers passing through each day. Those assigned to the job were unable to locate Andrew among the Throne. The fact that Andrew had travelled to King's Cross was a major revelation, but it raised even more questions. Over the summer holidays, Andrew's parents had given him the option of going to London to stay with his grandmother, but he'd refused. So, why go there now without asking for permission?
戈斯登一家拿到了一份最新版的《Time Out》，这是一份免费的每周指南，详细介绍了城里发生的所有最新活动。他们仔细查看了每一页，寻找任何可能促使安德鲁旅行的原因。凯文最近带孩子们去伦敦看了《狮子王》现场演出。这是安德鲁看过的第一场大型摇滚音乐会，他非常享受这次体验。戈斯登夫妇调查了2007年9月14日星期五还有哪些乐队在伦敦演出。
The Gossden family got their hands on a copy of the latest edition of Time Out, a free weekly guide detailing all the latest events happening in the city. They scoured each page on the lookout for anything that might have motivated Andrews travels. Kevin had recently taken his children to London to watch him use Play Live. It was the first major rock concert that Andrew had been to, and he thoroughly enjoyed the experience. The Gossetans looked into what other bands were playing in London on Friday, September 14, 2007.
他们考虑安德鲁是否可能为了一个音乐和观光的周末而去了这座城市。也许他遵循的是“先斩后奏”的心态。美国摇滚乐队30 Seconds to Mars那天晚上在布里克斯顿学院（Brixton Academy）演出。据戈斯登夫妇所知，安德鲁并不熟悉他们的音乐。一个名为SICKTH的布拉格金属乐队在O2伊斯灵顿学院（O2 Academy Islington）演出，距离国王十字车站步行约15分钟。虽然戈斯登夫妇不知道安德鲁是否知道SICKTH，但该乐队确实与
They considered whether Andrew could have taken off to the city for a weekend of music and sightseeing. Perhaps he was following the mentality of asking for forgiveness rather than permission. American rock band 30 seconds to Mars were playing that night at Brixton Academy. As far as the Gossens were aware, Andrew wasn't familiar with their music. A Prague metal band called SICKTH were playing at the O2 Academy Islington, which was about a 15-minute walk from King's Cross. Although the Gossden's didn't know if Andrew knew of Sixth, the band did have a link to
活结乐队（Slipknot）有联系。这也是一场重要的演出，是主唱米奇·古德曼（Mikey Goodman）最后一次出现在阵容中。此外，芬兰摇滚乐队HIM将于9月17日在HMV唱片店进行店内签名会，而安德鲁是他们音乐的粉丝。如果音乐不是动机，安德鲁的父母想知道他是否可能去伦敦寻求工作经验。他的姐姐夏洛特在安德鲁这个年纪时就做过。
Slipknot. It was a significant show, too, being the last time singer Mikey Goodman would feature on the line-up. Furthermore, Finnish rock band Him were doing an in-store signing at a HMV record store on the 17th of September, and Andrew was a fan of their music. If music wasn't the motivation, Andrew's parents wondered whether it could have gone to London seeking work experience. His sister Charlotte had done so at Andrew's age.
他想追随她的脚步是有可能的。他只买了一张单程票的事实对戈斯登夫妇来说似乎并不太奇怪。也许他犯了一个暂时的错误，并不完全确定他的计划，或者打算在家里的一位朋友或亲戚那里过夜。这个理论的问题在于，这些人中没有一个见过
It was possible he wanted to follow in her footsteps. The fact that he'd only bought a one-way ticket didn't seem too strange to the Gossden's. Perhaps he'd made a momentary error, wasn't entirely sure of his plans, or intended to spend the night with one of the family's friends or relatives. The problem with this theory was that none of these people had seen
或收到过安德鲁的消息。警方对每个人都进行了调查，没有发现任何迹象表明他们与这名14岁的少年有过接触。当时，伦敦16岁以下儿童乘坐公交车是免费的，这意味着安德鲁有办法在城里走动。但他带走的200英镑在食物和住所方面走不了多远。这导致了安德鲁可能露宿街头的可能性，使他容易受到繁忙城市街道中潜伏的危险的影响。如果安德鲁离开家时并不打算回来，那么
or heard from Andrew. Police made inquiries with each one and found nothing to indicate that they'd crossed paths with the 14-year-old. At the time, Basin's tram travel was free for children under 16 in London, meaning Andrew would have had the means to get around town. But the 200 pounds that he'd taken with him wouldn't get him very far in terms of food and shelter. This led to the possibility that Andrew was sleeping rough, making him vulnerable to the dangers that lurked in the busy city streets. If Andrew had left home without intending to return, it didn't make sense
他没有带换洗衣服，或者至少没有带一件保暖的套头衫，这说不通。安德鲁是一个习惯成自然的人，喜欢家庭的舒适。尽管他很聪明，但他缺乏社会经验。他看起来也比14岁年轻得多。他的家人认为他不会自愿让自己处于一个不舒服、危险的境地。这导致了另一种可能性。Casefile稍后回来。感谢您通过收听本集的赞助商来支持我们。感谢您收听本集的广告，以继续提供优质内容。安德鲁·戈斯登在伦敦见过什么人吗？
that he hadn't brought a change of clothes or at the very least a warm jumper. Andrew was a creature of habit who enjoyed home comforts. For all his intelligence, he lacked street smarts. He also looked much younger than 14. His family didn't think he would willingly put himself in an uncomfortable, dangerous position. That led to another possibility. Casefile will be back shortly. Thank you for supporting us by listening to this episode's sponsors. Thank you for listening to this episode's ads. to continue to deliver quality content. Did Andrew Gosden meet someone in London?
鉴于他大部分业余时间都待在家里，这使他几乎没有机会在学校之外与人接触。从安德鲁小时候起，他就参加了童子军和教会。在他失踪前的几个月里，他停止了参加这两项活动。对他的家人来说，这并没有什么可疑之处。安德鲁曾以无聊为由离开童子军，
Given that he spent most of his spare time at home, this left him with very little opportunities to cross paths with someone outside of school. Ever since Andrew was a young boy, he'd attended Boy Scouts and Church. In the months leading up to his disappearance, he'd stopped going to both. For his family, there was nothing suspicious about this. Andrew had cited boredom as the reason for leaving Scouts
而他的父母认为他可能只是追随夏洛特的脚步停止去教堂。警方对这两个组织的成员进行了调查。没有证据表明安德鲁因为任何其他原因停止参加。前一年夏天，即2006年，安德鲁作为天才少年计划的一部分参加了暑期学校。这是一个寄宿项目，要求他离开家两周。他很享受这次经历，并以极好的心情回到了家。
and his parents thought he was likely just following in Charlotte's footsteps by stopping church. Inquiries were made with members of both organizations. No evidence emerged to indicate that Andrew stopped going for any other reasons. The previous summer of 2006, Andrew had attended summer school as part of the gifted and talented youth program. It was a residential program that required him to spend two weeks away from home. He'd embraced the experience and returned home in a great mood.
一些人推测他是否可能在此期间与某人建立了联系，但没有证据支持这一点。安德鲁的同学和老师也无法说明他为什么去伦敦。戈斯登家只有一台电脑，是夏洛特最近生日时收到的笔记本电脑。在接下来的八周里，安德鲁几乎没碰过它。他从未对电脑表现出太大兴趣。据他的家人所知，安德鲁甚至没有电子邮件地址。当时，社交媒体还处于起步阶段，安德鲁没有表现出参与的欲望。Facebook和MySpace是主要的社交网站，但安德鲁
Some speculated whether he could have connected with someone during this time, but there was no evidence to support this. Andrew's classmates and teachers were also unable to shed any light on why he traveled to London. The Gossden household only had one computer, a laptop that Charlotte had recently received for her birthday. Andrew had barely touched it in the eight weeks since. He'd never shown much interest in computers. As far as his family was aware, Andrew didn't even have an email address. At the time, social media was still in its infancy, and Andrew had shown no desire to participate. Facebook and MySpace were the major networking sites, but Andrew
这两个平台都没有账户。对夏洛特笔记本电脑的检查未能发现任何迹象表明安德鲁曾在网上与任何人交谈。他没有进行任何暗示他为什么去伦敦，或者他到达那里后有什么打算的在线搜索。安德鲁使用的电脑也从他的学校和当地的唐卡斯特图书馆被查封。在其中任何一台电脑上都没有发现有助于调查的内容。戈斯登家里的电话线也没有任何无法解释的活动。鉴于安德鲁没有手机，这意味着他访问
didn't have an account with either platform. Examination of Charlotte's laptop failed to uncover anything to indicate that Andrew had been talking to anyone online. He hadn't conducted any online searches that hinted as to why he'd travelled to London, or what his intentions were once he got there. Computers used by Andrew were also seized from his school and to the local Donkaster library. Nothing was found on any of them that helped with the investigation. There was no inexplicable activity on the GOSD and family's home phone line. Given that Andrew didn't have a mobile, this meant the only other way he could have accessed
互联网的唯一其他方式是通过他的游戏机。安德鲁的Xbox没有在线功能，但他的PlayStation Portable有。他本可以通过其文本、语音或视频聊天功能与他人交流。这样做需要他拥有一个在线账户，而这反过来又需要他拥有一个电子邮件地址。对PlayStation生产商索尼的检查显示，安德鲁·戈斯登不存在这样的账户。戈斯登夫妇最担心的是安德鲁被恋童癖者或人口贩子诱骗，并以虚假借口被引诱到伦敦。由于安德鲁的高智商，他比同龄人成熟，并且一直
the internet was via one of his gaming consoles. Andrew's Xbox didn't have online capabilities, but his PlayStation portable did. He would have been able to communicate with others using its text, voice or video chat features. Doing so would require him to have an online account, which would in turn require him to have an email address. Checks with PlayStation's producer Sony revealed no such account existed for Andrew Gossden. no such account existed for Andrew Gosden. The Gosden's worst fear was that Andrew was groomed by a pedophile or sex trafficker and Lewittalundan under false pretense. Due to Andrew's high intelligence, he was mature for his age and had always related
与成年人相处得特别好。虽然安德鲁从未表达过，但他的家人考虑了他可能一直在与自己的性取向作斗争，并因为感到羞耻或太尴尬而不敢出柜，从而离家出走的可能性。如果是这样，这也可能解释为什么他更容易受到年长男性的诱骗。但由于没有手机或在线活动支持这一理论，安德鲁是如何与掠夺者接触的还有待观察。
particularly well to adults. Although Andrew had never expressed it, his family considered the possibility that he could have been struggling with his sexual orientation and had run away because he felt ashamed or too awkward to come out. If this was the case, it could also explain why he might be more susceptible to grooming by an older male. But with no phone or online activity supporting this theory, it remained to be seen how Andrew could have come into contact with the predator.
在他失踪前的那个星期，安德鲁的日常习惯发生了轻微的变化。虽然他通常乘巴士上学，但在新学年里，他两次选择步行，这是一段四英里的路程，步行大约需要一个小时二十分钟。这名少年可能在此期间被某人接近过。他可能秘密地得到了一部手机，专门用来与这个人交谈。两人可能出于某种原因计划在伦敦见面，诱骗者承诺给安德鲁回家的车费，这就是为什么他只买了一张单程票。但安德鲁的家人告诉《泰晤士报》，这些长途步行可能只是
In the week leading up to his disappearance, there had been a slight change in Andrew's routine. While he typically caught the buster school, in the new academic year he'd twice chosen to walk instead, a four mile trip that took around an hour and twenty minutes on foot. The teenager could have been approached by someone during this time. He could have secretly been given a mobile phone which he used exclusively to speak with this person. The two could have made plans to meet in London for one reason or another, with the grim a promising Andrew a ride home, hence why he had only bought a one-way ticket. But Andrew's family told the Times that these long walks could have just as easily
为了未来流浪街头的计划而进行的练习。凯文和格拉尼斯·戈斯登多次往返于伦敦，在街上搜寻他们的儿子。他们走访了他曾经表现出兴趣的所有地点，在他们能想到的每一个博物馆、火车站、餐馆和收容所分发失踪人员海报。他们尽可能多地制造媒体关注，尽其所能让安德鲁的案件保持在公众意识中。
been practiced for a future plan of wandering the streets. Kevin and Glenis Gosden traveled to and from London numerous times scouring the streets for their son. They visited all the sites that he'd ever shown interest in, distributing missing person posters at every museum, train station, restaurant, and homeless shelter they could think of. They drummed up as much media as possible, doing whatever they could to keep Andrew's case in the public consciousness.
几名目击者认为他们在安德鲁失踪当天见过他。一次所谓的目击发生在牛津街的一家必胜客餐厅，距离国王十字车站仅几步之遥。这位目击者描述男孩举止的方式使戈斯登夫妇认为这次目击是可信的，但警方无法证实。另一名目击者报告说，看到一个符合安德鲁描述的人在伦敦南岸区露宿。另一个人认为他们在伦敦南岸公园附近看到了安德鲁
Several witnesses believed that they'd seen Andrew on the day he went missing. One alleged sighting took place at a pizza hut restaurant on Oxford Street, just a short walk from King's Cross Station. The way this witness described the boy's mannerisms led the Gossens to believe that this sighting was credible, but the police were unable to confirm it. Another witness reported seeing someone matching Andrew's description sleeping rough near London's South Bank District. Another believed they'd seen Andrew at a South Bank Park near the London
议会大厦。戈斯登夫妇跟进了每一条线索，亲自访问这些地点询问当地人并寻找他们的儿子，但没有出现任何关于安德鲁下落的线索。随着日子一天天过去，没有任何突破，南约克郡警察局的警官被派往伦敦审查从国王十字车站拍摄的闭路电视录像。他们扫描了数百小时的录音，直到一些东西终于引起了他们的注意。上午11点24分，在从唐卡斯特出发的火车到达国王十字车站四分钟后，穿着黑色活结T恤的安德鲁·戈斯登那无可辨认的身影从人群中出现。这名少年独自从车站主入口平静地离开，然后消失在
Assembly Building. The Gossens followed up every lead, visiting these locations for themselves to question locals and to look for their son, but not a single clue as to Andrew's whereabouts emerged. As days passed with no breakthroughs, officers from South Yorkshire Police were sent to London to review the CCTV footage taken from King's Cross Station. They scanned through hundreds of hours of recordings before something finally caught their attention. At 11.24am, four minutes after the train from Donkaster arrived at King's Cross Station, the unmistakable side of Andrew Gostern in his black slipknot t-shirt emerged from the crowd. The teenager unremarkably exited through the station's main entrance alone before disappearing
视野中。当警方发现这一目击事件时，安德鲁已经失踪了27天。这对戈斯登一家来说是一个苦乐参半的发现。他们对他们所认为的“缓慢、混乱和无组织”的警察反应感到沮丧。国王十字车站本质上是一个换乘站。那里有大量的其他地铁站和公交车站，包括一个有通往欧洲其他地区线路的国际车站。现有的闭路电视录像只证实了安德鲁在伦敦下了火车。他没有显示出从那里开始的行动迹象。安德鲁没有带他的护照
from view. By the time police uncovered this sighting, Andrew had been missing for 27 days. It was a bittersweet discovery for the Gossden family. They were frustrated by what they perceived to be a quote, slow, chaotic and disorganized police response. King's cross essentially acts as an interchange station. A plethora of other tube stations and bus stops are located there, including an international station with links to other parts of Europe. The existing CCTV footage only confirmed that Andrew disembarked the train in London. He gave no indication as to his movements from there. Andrew hadn't taken his passport
随身携带，这使得他不太可能继续前往另一个国家。但完全有可能他下了这列火车，又上了另一列火车。伦敦被认为是世界上监控最严密的城市之一。据一些消息来源称，住在伦敦的普通人每天可能被闭路电视拍到多达300次。但令戈斯登一家沮丧的是，警方没有要求检查任何其他摄像头的录像。当要求查看当地政府拥有的闭路电视录像时，已经没有这样的录像了。按照协议，录音只保留一定天数，然后磁带
with him, making it unlikely that he travelled onwards to another country. But it was entirely possible that he could have gotten off one train and astrayed on to another. London is considered to be one of the most heavily-surveiled cities in the world. According to some sources, the average person living in London can be caught on CCTV up to 300 times per day. But to the dismay of the Gossden family, police hadn't requested to check the footage from any other cameras. By the time requests were made to view CCTV footage owned by local authorities, no such footage existed. As was protocol, recordings were only kept for a certain number of days before the tapes
被擦除。到10月17日星期三，已经过去了一个多月，仍然没有安德鲁的消息。正如BBC电视节目《Missing Live》所报道的那样，一名叫菲利帕（Philippa）的女子站在伦敦科文特花园区（Covent Garden District）的一条繁忙街道上，注意到一名路人与安德鲁·戈斯登有相似之处。菲利帕走近那个男孩并试图与他交谈，说他看起来像那个失踪的少年。男孩否认自己是安德鲁·戈斯登，但菲利帕的好奇心被激起了。
were wiped clean. By Wednesday, October 17, over a month had passed with no word from Andrew. As reported on the BBC television program Missing Live, a woman named Philippa was standing on a busy street in London's Covent Garden District, when she noticed a passer by who bore similarities to Andrew Gossden. Philippa approached the boy and tried to engage him in conversation, remarking that he looked like the missing teenager. The boy denied being Andrew Gosden, but Philippa's curiosity was peaked.
她跟着那个男孩，直到在一家名为“诗歌之地”（The Poetry Place）的咖啡馆附近失去了他的踪影。菲利帕向警方报告了这次潜在的目击事件。据戈斯登夫妇说，直到六周后才跟进。菲利帕与男孩交谈的地点在办公大楼外。闭路电视摄像头安装在建筑物入口处，但在所谓的互动发生时并没有工作。当她看到安德鲁·戈斯登的照片时，“诗歌之地”的一名员工认为她可能在咖啡馆里看到过他，当时他正和两个女孩在一起。
She followed the boy until losing sight of him near a cafe called the poetry place. Philippa reported this potential sighting to police. According to the Gossden, it wasn't followed up until six weeks later. The location where Philippa spoke to the boy was outside of an office building. CCTV cameras were fitted to the entrance of the building, but weren't working at the time the alleged interaction took place. When she was a picture of Andrew Gosden and employee at the poetry place thought she might have seen him in the cafe in the company of two girls.
虽然她承认那可能只是一个长相相似的人，因为该地区的许多十几岁男孩都有类似的时髦发型。菲利帕的目击是否合法，无法确定。关于安德鲁的目击报告不断传来，有些甚至远至南威尔士。据凯文·戈斯登说，警方要么对这些线索反应迟钝，要么根本没有跟进。凯文认为他们的重点仍然是揭开安德鲁为什么离家出走，而不是从那以后发生了什么。随着圣诞节临近，警方要求在警告下审问凯文·戈斯登。
Although she acknowledged it could have just been someone who looked similar, as many teenage boys in the area had a similar trendy haircut. Whether Philip's sighting was legitimate or not, couldn't be ascertained. Reported sightings of Andrew continued to come in, some from as far as South Wales. According to Kevin Gossden, the police were either slack to respond to these leads, or didn't follow them up at all. Kevin believed that their focus remained on uncovering why Andrew had left home, rather than what happened from there. As Christmas approached, the police asked to question Kevin Gossden under caution.
对凯文来说，这是最后一根稻草。他确信警方没有做出更大努力寻找他儿子的原因是，他们把时间和资源浪费在调查他作为安德鲁失踪的主要嫌疑人上。一个念头在凯文脑海中挥之不去。如果他把自己从画面中移除，迫使警方专注于寻找他的儿子呢？圣诞节前夕的一天，牧师艾伦·默里带着一些食物来到戈斯登家，渴望以任何方式提供帮助。当艾伦走近门口时，他听到里面传来一声重物落地的声音。
For Kevin, this was the last straw. He was convinced that the reason police weren't making a greater effort to find his son was because they were wasting their time and resources on investigating him as the prime suspect in Andrew's disappearance. A thought nought away at Kevin. What if he removed himself from the picture, forcing the police to focus on the search for his son instead? One day in the lead up to Christmas, Vigor Allen Murray went to the Goslands house with some food, eager to help in any way he could. As Allen approached the door, he heard a crushing noise coming from inside.
他用备用钥匙自己进去了。在那里，艾伦发现凯文·戈斯登吊在楼上的栏杆上。他设法把凯文救了下来并送往医院，经过7个小时他才恢复意识。凯文在接下来的几个月里在一家心理健康机构接受治疗，他告诉《约克郡邮报》：“我无法开始描述这所涉及的痛苦深度。没有任何治疗有帮助，因为这种情况是不可逆转的。”
He let himself in using a spare key. There, Alan found Kevin Gossden hanging from the upstairs baller-straight. He managed to cut Kevin down and rush him to hospital, where it took 7 hours before he regained consciousness. Kevin spent the next few months receiving treatment in a mental health facility, telling the Yorkshire Post, I cannot begin to describe the depths of misery that this involved. No amount of therapy helped because the situation was unreservable.
尽管精疲力竭，戈斯登一家仍继续尽其所能让安德鲁的案件保持在聚光灯下，出现在众多的电视和广播节目中，并与任何愿意倾听的记者交谈。凯文成为了家庭的发言人，建立了一个名为“帮助我们找到安德鲁”（Help Us Find Andrew）的案件专题网站，他在那里分享新闻，以及安德鲁快乐童年的照片和关于他失踪影响的博客文章。警方最终没有发现任何证据表明戈斯登一家除了他们自称的那个亲密、充满爱心和支持的家庭之外还有其他身份。一位认识戈斯登一家10年的安德鲁的朋友告诉《每日邮报》，
Strained but untotored, the Gossians continued doing all they could to keep Andrew's case in the spotlight, appearing on numerous television and radio shows, and speaking to any reporter willing to listen. Kevin became the family's spokesperson, establishing a website dedicated to the case titled Help Us Find Andrew, where he shared news along with photos of Andrew's happy childhood and to blog posts about the impact of him being missing. Police ultimately found no evidence to indicate that the gostens were anything other than the close-knit, loving and supportive family that they described themselves to be. A friend of Andrews who had known the Gossden family for 10 years told the Daily Mail,
人们想知道家里是否发生了什么事，但我知道事实并非如此。他们是我认识的最友好的家庭之一。这使得安德鲁·戈斯登的失踪更加令人费解。据他的老师说，安德鲁是剑桥大学的当然人选。但尽管他很聪明，但他对学习从未表现出特别的热情。在凯文看来，安德鲁将学校视为确保他未来有选择权的必要条件。也许他厌倦了或对为他设定的传统道路感到沮丧，并离家出走去开始新的生活。安德鲁最喜欢的电视节目之一是《The Rise and Fall》。
people wonder if something was happening at home, but I know for a fact that's not true. They're one of the nicest families I know. This made Andrew Gossden's disappearance all the more baffling. According to his teachers, Andrew had been a shoe-in for Cambridge University. But despite his intelligence, he'd never been particularly enthusiastic about his studies. The way Kevin saw it, Andrew viewed school as a necessity to ensure he had choices in the future. Maybe he'd gotten bored or frustrated with the conventional path set out for him and had run away to start a new life. One of Andrew's favourite television shows was The Rise and Fall
人们怀疑家里是否发生了什么事，但我可以肯定事实并非如此。他们是我认识的最友善的家庭之一。这让安德鲁·戈斯登的失踪变得更加令人费解。据他的老师说，安德鲁本来是剑桥大学的稳录人选。但尽管他很聪明，却从未对学业表现出特别的热情。在凯文看来，安德鲁将学校视为确保未来有选择权的必要途径。也许他厌倦或挫败于为他设定的传统道路，于是离家出走去开启新生活。安德鲁最喜欢的电视节目之一是《兴衰史》。
of Reginald Paran. The British sitcom was about a man who faked his own death to escape the daily grind. Prior to his disappearance, Andrew had also been reading the work of famous philosopher Friedrich Nietzsche. He encouraged people to be free thinkers, find their own values, and stand out among the masses. As his mother told the telegraph, maybe Andrew wanted to step off the treadmill. But the theory that Andrew had run away to start a new life didn't quite fit. Those close to Andrew knew him to be nothing but sweet and thoughtful. They didn't think he was capable of putting his family through such immense suffering.
雷金纳德·帕兰。这部英国情景喜剧讲述了一个男人为了逃避日常生活而伪造自己死亡的故事。在失踪之前，安德鲁也一直在阅读著名哲学家弗里德里希·尼采的著作。他鼓励人们成为自由思想者，寻找自己的价值观，并在人群中脱颖而出。正如他母亲告诉《每日电讯报》的那样，也许安德鲁想从这种单调的生活中走出来。但安德鲁离家出走开始新生活的理论并不完全成立。那些了解安德鲁的人都知道他是一个非常贴心和体贴的人。他们不认为他有能力让家人承受如此巨大的痛苦。
Four months before Andrew vanished, three-year-old Madeline McCann went missing from her family's holiday villa in Portugal. The story had dominated the news in the UK. Kevin and Andrew had spoken about how awful it was. If Andrew wanted to disappear for good, those close to him felt sure that he'd have left a note who made some kind of contact by now. On top of the fact that he didn't bring more personal belongings with him, was the fact
在安德鲁失踪前四个月，三岁的马德琳·麦肯在葡萄牙的家庭度假别墅中失踪。这个故事曾占据了英国新闻的头条。凯文和安德鲁曾谈论过这件事有多可怕。如果安德鲁真的想彻底消失，那些了解他的人确信他到现在一定会留下字条或以某种方式联系他们。除了他没有带走更多个人物品这一事实外，还有
that he hadn't brought more money. Although Andrew had essentially cleared out his bank account, he'd left almost 100 pounds in birthday money untouched in his bedroom. The family also kept a box full of emergency cash for bus fares and the like, but Andrew hadn't taken any of it. Given Andrew's age and the fact that he looked even younger than his 14 years, it was unlikely that he could have secured legitimate work, or started a new life without adult help. His disappearance was also highly publicized. If Andrew was squatting somewhere, sleeping rough, where it got in court up with the wrong
他没有带走更多的钱。虽然安德鲁基本上清空了他的银行账户，但他卧室里留下了近100英镑的生日礼金，分文未动。家里还放着一个装满应急现金的盒子，用于支付公交车费等开销，但安德鲁一点也没拿。考虑到安德鲁的年龄，而且他看起来比14岁还要小，他不太可能在没有成年人帮助的情况下找到合法工作或开始新生活。他的失踪也受到了高度关注。如果安德鲁躲在某个地方，露宿街头，或者陷入了错误的
crowd, it seemed to mind-boggling that someone somewhere wouldn't have recognized him. Before Andrew went missing, he'd expressed his desire to grow his hair long and die at black. If he was trying to evade detection, he could have just as easily shaved his head or bleached his hair blonde. Even if he did alter his looks, there was no getting away from the unique double ridge on his upper right ear. That led to the next possibility. The reason that Andrew hadn't made contacts or been found was because he was no longer alive. If Andrew was indeed being groomed, he might have been kidnapped upon his arrival to London. It could have been part of a carefully orchestrated plan involving one or multiple perpetrators,
圈子，那么有人在某个地方认出他似乎是不可思议的。在安德鲁失踪前，他曾表示想留长发并染成黑色。如果他想逃避侦查，他完全可以剃光头或把头发漂成金色。即使他改变了外貌，也无法掩盖他右耳上独特的双重隆起。这引出了下一个可能性。安德鲁没有联系或被发现的原因是他已经不在人世了。如果安德鲁确实被诱拐了，他可能在抵达伦敦后就被绑架了。这可能是涉及一名或多名肇事者的精心策划的一部分，
which ultimately ended in Andrew being held captive or killed. But if Andrew had full and victim to foul play, it wasn't necessarily a premeditated attack. It was just as possible that Andrew had trouble to London of his own accord, simply to have an adventure. He could have had every intention of returning home without his family finding out, before crossing paths with the wrong person. Andrew's age and the fact that he was traveling alone would have made him particularly vulnerable to opportunistic criminals. He could have been the victim
最终导致安德鲁被囚禁或杀害。但如果安德鲁确实遭遇了不测，这并不一定是一次预谋的袭击。同样有可能的是，安德鲁是自愿前往伦敦，只是为了冒险。他可能完全打算在不让家人发现的情况下回家，却在途中遇到了错误的人。安德鲁的年龄以及他独自旅行的事实使他特别容易受到机会主义罪犯的伤害。他可能成为了
of a robbery gone wrong, or placed his trust in a stranger who ultimately caused him harm. Alternatively, his death could have been the result of an accident. If Andrew hadn't voluntarily run away, fall and vig them to fair play, or been involved in an accident, it left just one other possibility. Andrew had never shown any signs of depression or self-harm. Regardless, the possibility that he could have taken his own life was considered. Andrew had always been a deep thinker. While it seemed unthinkable to his family, it was possible that Andrew had an inner world that he'd never revealed to anyone else.
抢劫案的受害者，或者信任了一个最终伤害他的人。或者，他的死亡可能是一场意外的结果。如果安德鲁不是自愿离家出走、遭遇不测或卷入事故，那就只剩下最后一种可能性了。安德鲁从未表现出任何抑郁或自残的迹象。尽管如此，他可能自杀的可能性还是被考虑到了。安德鲁一直是个深思熟虑的人。虽然这对他的家人来说似乎是不可想象的，但安德鲁可能有一个他从未向任何人透露过的内心世界。
Perhaps he'd gone to London to spend one final day enjoying some of his favorite sites before ending things for good, saving his family the trauma of discovering his body. This could explain why he only bought a one-way ticket and hadn't bothered to bring a jacket or the charger for his PlayStation portable. Yet, it didn't explain why he'd taken his keys, or why he hadn't left a note for his family, whom he knew would be worried sick.
也许他去伦敦是为了在彻底结束生命之前，最后一天享受一下他最喜欢的地方，从而让家人免受发现他尸体的创伤。这可以解释为什么他只买了一张单程票，而且没有带夹克或PlayStation便携式游戏机的充电器。然而，这并不能解释他为什么要带走钥匙，或者为什么没有给家人留下字条，因为他知道他们会担心得要命。
Most significantly, it didn't explain the absence of a body. The Gossden family remained insistent that Andrew hadn't been bullied. His sister Charlotte attended the same school and was an active member of an anti-bullying program. It was an issue often discussed at the family dinner table and Andrew had never mentioned any problems. This was supported by one of Andrew's teachers who told the Times.
最重要的是，这无法解释尸体的缺失。戈斯登一家坚持认为安德鲁没有受到欺凌。他的姐姐夏洛特就读于同一所学校，并且是一个反欺凌项目的积极成员。这是一个在家庭餐桌上经常讨论的问题，而安德鲁从未提到过任何问题。安德鲁的一位老师也支持这一点，他告诉《泰晤士报》。
Andrew is deep and mature beyond his years. He's quite happy and self-contained in his own company, but he's not a loner. He always had a little posse of friends with him. Likewise, the school principal said, Andrew is a very likable, self-effacing boy. No one's got a bad word to say about him. This is not the sort of school where you can get lost in the system. If there had been any bullying going on, we'd have known about it. In the wake of Andrew's disappearance, a post appeared on an online forum hosted by
安德鲁思想深邃，比同龄人更成熟。他很乐于独处，也很自足，但他不是一个孤独的人。他身边总有一群小伙伴。同样，校长也说，安德鲁是一个非常讨人喜欢、谦逊的男孩。没有人对他有任何负面评价。这不是那种会被系统遗忘的学校。如果发生了任何欺凌事件，我们一定会知道的。在安德鲁失踪后，一个在线论坛上出现了一篇帖子，该论坛由
British Music magazine Corang. According to a user who identified themselves only as Bax, she attended the same school as Andrew and the two were in all of the same classes. Bax wrote, Andrew did get singled out a lot and only had a couple of friends. People bullied him. They wonder why he ran away. If true, it offered a reason why Andrew had recently avoided taking the school bus.
英国音乐杂志《Kerrang!》主办。据一位只自称为Bax的用户称，她和安德鲁在同一所学校，两人在所有课程中都在一起。Bax写道，安德鲁确实经常被针对，只有几个朋友。人们欺负他。他们想知道他为什么离家出走。如果这是真的，它解释了安德鲁最近为什么避免乘坐校车。
It also explained why he ditched school completely, sort a new beginning, or took his own life. But as the weeks turned into months, none of the belongings Andrew left home where Thun September 14 surfaced. If Andrew had gone to London or beyond to end his own life, chances were that at least something would show up to prove this theory. The same went for the possibility that Andrew had innocently traveled to London to play hooky for the day and been involved in a fatal accident. Most accidents would attract attention, yet no one had witnessed a thing. The river Tams runs through Central London.
这也解释了他为什么完全逃学、寻求新的开始或自杀。但随着几周变成几个月，安德鲁在9月14日离家时留下的任何物品都没有出现。如果安德鲁去伦敦或更远的地方结束自己的生命，很有可能至少会有一些东西出现来证明这个理论。同样的情况也适用于安德鲁无意中去伦敦逃学一天并卷入致命事故的可能性。大多数事故都会引起注意，但没有人目击到任何事情。泰晤士河穿过伦敦市中心。
Even if Andrew had intentionally jumped or accidentally fallen in, someone would have noticed or a body would have surfaced. Every potential outcome just raised even more questions. Case file will be back shortly. Thank you for supporting us by listening to this episode's sponsors. Thank you for listening to this episode's ads. By supporting our sponsors, you support CaseFile to continue to deliver quality content. By the time Andrew Gosden had been missing for a year, a total of 122 unconfirmed sightings
即使安德鲁是有意跳河或意外落水，也会有人注意到，或者尸体会浮出水面。每一个潜在的结果都引发了更多的问题。案件档案稍后回来。感谢您通过收听本期节目的赞助商来支持我们。感谢您收听本期节目的广告。通过支持我们的赞助商，您支持了CaseFile继续提供高质量的内容。当安德鲁·戈斯登失踪一年时，总共收到了122条未经证实的目击报告，
had come in from all over the UK. A church service was held in London to mark the anniversary, with Kevin and Glenis Gossden panning an open letter to their son that read, We have all missed you so much since the day you left, not a day goes by that you are not in our minds constantly. If you should ever read this, forget about any water under the bridge, and please have no fear about making contact with us. We do not care where you have been or what lifestyle you choose for yourself. We only want to know that you are safe and well and to help and to support you if we can.
来自英国各地。伦敦举行了一场教堂仪式以纪念周年纪念日，凯文和格莱尼斯·戈斯登给他们的儿子写了一封公开信，信中写道，自从你离开的那天起，我们所有人都非常想念你，没有一天不在时刻想念你。如果你能读到这封信，请忘记过去的一切不快，请不要害怕与我们联系。我们不在乎你去过哪里或选择了什么样的生活方式。我们只想知道你平安健康，如果可以的话，我们想帮助和支持你。
We remain as proud of you as we have always been and to love you deeply. In conjunction with the anniversary, Andrew's face was printed on milk cartons in Iceland as part of a widespread missing persons campaign. A month later, Kevin and Glynner shared their story on BBC's popular current affairs program, The One Show. Within hours, the Intercom buzzed at the LEMSTAR police station, a market town 150 miles south east of London. The station was located in a business park and the desk wasn't manned around the clock. Instead, visitors could announce their arrival via an intercom outside.
我们依然像过去一样为你感到骄傲，并深深地爱着你。为了配合周年纪念，安德鲁的头像被印在冰岛的牛奶盒上，作为广泛失踪人口运动的一部分。一个月后，凯文和格莱尼斯在BBC受欢迎的时事节目《The One Show》中分享了他们的故事。几小时内，位于伦敦东南150英里的集镇莱明斯特警察局的对讲机响了。该警察局位于一个商业园区内，前台并非全天候有人值守。相反，访客可以通过外面的对讲机宣布他们的到来。
A male voice said he wanted to report a sighting of Andrew Gossden. An officer was sent down to take the details. By the time they arrived, the man was gone. Shortly after, an anonymous letter arrived at the BBC offices. The author claimed to have been the man who fled from Alemster Station. He said that Andrew had been spotted in the town of Shroesbury, 150 miles northwest of London. Police were unable to verify this claim or even confirmed that the two informants were one and the same, adding to what Kevin
一个男声说他想报告一起安德鲁·戈斯登的目击事件。一名警官被派去记录细节。当他们到达时，那个人已经离开了。不久之后，一封匿名信寄到了BBC办公室。作者声称自己就是那个从莱明斯特警察局逃走的人。他说安德鲁在伦敦西北150英里的什鲁斯伯里镇被发现。警方无法核实这一说法，甚至无法确认这两名举报人是否为同一人，这增加了凯文所描述的
Gosten described as a new form of subtle torture. He told the Donkhaast a press. Andrew knows that part of the world we've been on holiday there, but we don't really know enough. Perhaps there's somebody that knows something that we don't. But the longer it goes, the more we get thinking he's probably either dead, or not free. If he's still alive, I suspect that he'll wait until his 16th birthday next July to show his hand. Andrew's birthday came and went with no breakthroughs. Since Kevin's suicide attempt in 2007, he'd been unable to work, plagued by depression,
一种新型的微妙折磨。他告诉《唐卡斯特自由报》。安德鲁了解世界的那一部分，我们曾在那里度假，但我们了解得还不够。也许有人知道一些我们不知道的事情。但时间越长，我们越觉得他可能已经死了，或者失去了自由。如果他还活着，我怀疑他会等到明年7月他16岁生日时才露面。安德鲁的生日过去了，没有任何突破。自2007年凯文试图自杀以来，他一直无法工作，饱受抑郁、
anxiety, and post-traumatic stress disorder. He did everything he could think of to find his son. He relayed messages to Andrew through the media, begging him to let them know he was safe. He emailed schools across the country and appealed to the gay community, telling Andrew that his family loved him unconditionally no matter what. He attended concerts and music festivals of bands he thought Andrew might like, handing out flyers and scanning the crowds for anyone who bore a resemblance to his son.
焦虑和创伤后应激障碍的折磨。他尽其所能寻找儿子。他通过媒体向安德鲁传达信息，恳求他让他们知道他是安全的。他给全国各地的学校发了电子邮件，并向同性恋社区呼吁，告诉安德鲁他的家人无条件地爱他，无论发生什么。他参加了安德鲁可能喜欢的乐队的音乐会和音乐节，分发传单并扫描人群，寻找任何长得像他儿子的人。
Kevin said, I've really just run out of ideas now. I suppose this is the last hope of finding out what has happened. A non-going concern for the Gossden's was how much Andrews appearance could have changed in two years. With the photos of him as a baby-faced 14-year-old still circulating, they worried that if Andrew was still alive, he might be unrecognizable. On the two-year anniversary of Andrews disappearance, his family worked with the charity organization
凯文说，我真的已经没主意了。我想这是找出发生了什么的最后希望。戈斯登一家持续关心的一个问题是，安德鲁在两年内可能发生了多大的变化。随着他14岁时那张稚气未脱的照片仍在流传，他们担心如果安德鲁还活着，他可能已经让人认不出来了。在安德鲁失踪两周年之际，他的家人与慈善机构
Missing People to produce several computer-generated images of what Andrew might look like with the passing of time. The images brought some comfort to his family, with Kevin remarking, It's reassuring to look at that and think, yes, I don't know you anywhere. By May 2011, three and a half years had passed with no developments. The gostens were growing increasingly certain that Andrew hadn't run away. Kevin told the BBC. We just find it impossible to conceive that he would allow us to go through all this for
“失踪人口”合作，制作了几张安德鲁随着时间推移可能长相的电脑生成图像。这些图像给他的家人带来了一些安慰，凯文评论道，看着这些照片并想“是的，我认得你”是令人欣慰的。到2011年5月，三年半过去了，没有任何进展。戈斯登一家越来越确信安德鲁没有离家出走。凯文告诉BBC，我们觉得他不可能让我们经历这一切
so long, without even some kind of message to let us know he's okay. Instead, the absence of confirmed sightings led the family to believe that Andrew must be dead. With the help of a friend, the Gossden's approach to private firm that specialized in advanced sonar technology typically used to locate drowning victims at sea. They arranged for a roughly seven mile portion of the River Thames to be searched from Woolwich Barrier to Tower Bridge in Central London. The sonar revealed a sunken boat, an upturned car, and finally, a body.
这么久，甚至连一点让我们知道他平安的消息都没有。相反，缺乏证实的目击报告使家人相信安德鲁一定已经死了。在一位朋友的帮助下，戈斯登一家联系了一家专门从事先进声纳技术的私人公司，该技术通常用于定位海上的溺水受害者。他们安排对泰晤士河约七英里长的河段进行了搜索，从伍尔维奇屏障到伦敦市中心的塔桥。声纳发现了一艘沉船、一辆翻倒的汽车，最后是一具尸体。
It wasn't Andrew. The results sparked mixed feelings for the Gossens. Kevin remarked that it was slightly positive because it raised a statistical possibility that Andrew was alive and well somewhere. But quote, it still leaves us in this horrible ongoing never-ending limbo of just thinking, why did you go? September 2017 marked 10 years since Andrew Gossden's disappearance.
那不是安德鲁。这一结果让戈斯登一家心情复杂。凯文评论说，这稍微积极一点，因为它提出了安德鲁在某个地方平安无事的统计可能性。但他说，“这仍然让我们陷入这种可怕的、持续的、永无止境的困境中，只是在想，你为什么要走？”2017年9月是安德鲁·戈斯登失踪10周年。
Police launched a fresh appeal for information circulating Andrew's DNA, fingerprints sent to dental and medical records to authorities and health care professionals. Given that Andrew relied on strong prescription glasses, if he was still alive, many believed he would have at the very least sought optical care at some point, perhaps making the switch to contact lenses to further alter his appearance. A police spokesperson urged to doctors, dentists or hospital staff who might have treated a 24-year-old man with no records from the previous 10 years to come forward. The call out was extended to any members of the general public who might currently know Andrew Gossden, but be unaware of his true identity.
警方发起了新的信息征集活动，将安德鲁的DNA、指纹、牙科和医疗记录分发给当局和医疗专业人员。鉴于安德鲁依赖强力处方眼镜，如果他还活着，许多人认为他至少会在某个时候寻求眼科护理，也许会改用隐形眼镜以进一步改变外貌。警方发言人敦促可能治疗过一名过去10年没有记录的24岁男子的医生、牙医或医院工作人员站出来。这一呼吁也扩大到了任何可能认识安德鲁·戈斯登但不知道他真实身份的公众成员。
Appealing to Andrew directly, the police spokesperson added, Please contact us, completely confidentially, and let us know you are safe and well, and we can reassure your family you have come to know harm. can reassure your family you have come to know harm. Andrew Gosden became the face of missing peoples find every child campaign. His age progression images appeared everywhere from doctors' offices and hospitals to bus stations, garbage trucks and shopping centers. The Gosden's even consulted with the behavioral analyst to try and figure out why Andrew might
警方发言人直接向安德鲁呼吁，请完全保密地联系我们，让我们知道你平安健康，我们可以让你的家人放心，你没有受到伤害。安德鲁·戈斯登成为了“失踪人口”组织“寻找每一个孩子”运动的代言人。他的年龄增长模拟图出现在从医生办公室、医院到公交车站、垃圾车和购物中心的各个地方。戈斯登一家甚至咨询了行为分析师，试图弄清楚安德鲁在失踪当天为什么可能
have gone to London on the day he went missing and whether there were any places they might not have thought to check. At the time, statistics released by the National Crime Agency revealed that 98% of children who go missing in England are found within one week. This put Andrew Gostern in the rare 2%. He was one of 3,000 people in the United Kingdom who had been missing for more than 10 years. To mark the decade long mystery, Kevin Gostern raised money for missing people by holding a 10-hour vow of silence. One hour for every year his son had been missing.
去了伦敦，以及是否有他们可能没想到的地方需要检查。当时，国家犯罪局发布的统计数据显示，英国98%的失踪儿童在一周内被找到。这使安德鲁·戈斯登处于那罕见的2%中。他是英国3000名失踪超过10年的人之一。为了纪念这个长达十年的谜团，凯文·戈斯登通过进行10小时的禁语活动为“失踪人口”组织筹集资金。他儿子失踪的每一年对应一小时。
Around this time, Michael Dixon, not his real name, was chatting online with a young man who went by the username Andy Roo. Andy Roo said he needed help. His partner had just walked out and he needed 200 pounds to pay his rent. Michael noticed that Andy Roo was listed as living in Lincoln, a city in the English Netherlands. Michael didn't live nearby, but he offered to transfer Andy Roo some money. Andy Roo declined the offer. He claimed he didn't have a bank account because he'd left home at the age of 14. Michael asked him why, wondering if it was because there had been problems at home.
大约在这个时候，迈克尔·迪克森（化名）正在网上与一个使用用户名“Andy Roo”的年轻人聊天。Andy Roo说他需要帮助。他的伴侣刚刚离开，他需要200英镑来支付房租。迈克尔注意到Andy Roo被列为居住在英格兰林肯市。迈克尔不住在附近，但他提出给Andy Roo转一些钱。Andy Roo拒绝了。他声称自己没有银行账户，因为他在14岁时就离家出走了。迈克尔问他为什么，想知道是否是因为家里出了问题。
Andy Roo responded, no, I just felt like it. He then cut the conversation short. Michael Dixon had seen the ongoing publicity about Andrew Gossden's disappearance and began wondering if Andy Rue and Andrew could be one and the same. He reached out to the Gossden family, whose interest was immediately sparked. When Andrew was a kid, his small bouncy demeanor earned him the family nickname Roo, as in Kangaroo. Although it could have been a coincidence, the ghostens were taking no chances. They notified police about this online interaction and an investigation was launched. Andrew's family met with Michael Dixon and travelled to Lincoln. They made inquiries
Andy Roo回答说，不，我只是想这么做。然后他结束了谈话。迈克尔·迪克森看到了关于安德鲁·戈斯登失踪的持续报道，开始怀疑Andy Roo和安德鲁是否是同一个人。他联系了戈斯登一家，他们的兴趣立即被激发了。安德鲁小时候，他活泼的举止为他赢得了家庭昵称“Roo”，即袋鼠。虽然这可能是一个巧合，但戈斯登一家不想放过任何机会。他们通知了警方关于这次在线互动的情况，并展开了调查。安德鲁的家人与迈克尔·迪克森会面并前往林肯。他们进行了询问
with locals and thousands of missing persons leaflets were distributed around town. Four possible sightings were reported, but none of them turned out to be Andrew Goston. Meanwhile, police made inquiries with the chat provider, the name of which has not been made public. The website administrators had recently made changes to their system during which a lot of the user data was lost. No information about who owned the Andy Ru profile was able to be ascertained. The Gossden's continued to work with specialists to release age progression images of what Andrew might look like as the years went by.
并向当地人分发了数千份失踪人口传单。报告了四起可能的目击事件，但没有一起是安德鲁·戈斯登。与此同时，警方向聊天服务提供商进行了询问，该提供商的名字尚未公开。网站管理员最近对他们的系统进行了更改，在此期间丢失了大量用户数据。无法确定谁拥有Andy Roo的个人资料。戈斯登一家继续与专家合作，发布安德鲁随着岁月流逝可能长相的年龄增长模拟图。
If he was still alive, investigators believed that the best chance of finding him was the distinctive double-redge on his right ear. If photos of Andrew were posted on social media sites like Facebook and Instagram, facial recognition software could pick up this unique detail. The possibility that Andrew could have left home that Friday to attend a concert in London before meeting foul play hadn't been excluded. Since 2015, metropolitan police had begun working with a team of so-called super-recognizers. These are individuals with innate above average skill for spotting faces in a crowd. Police appeared for anyone who
如果他还活着，调查人员认为找到他的最好机会是他右耳上独特的双重隆起。如果安德鲁的照片发布在Facebook和Instagram等社交媒体网站上，面部识别软件可以捕捉到这个独特的细节。安德鲁可能在那个周五离家去伦敦参加音乐会，然后遭遇不测的可能性并没有被排除。自2015年以来，伦敦警察厅开始与一个所谓的“超级识别者”团队合作。这些人天生具有在人群中识别面孔的超常技能。警方呼吁任何
had attended any concerts around London on the weekend of September 14, 2007, to come forward with any photos or videos they might have taken, so that the super recognises could scan them for anyone who looked like Andrew. In early 2020, the Gossetans received a word that Andrew's favourite band, Slippnotte, was touring the UK. If Andrew was still alive and living of his own free will, his family felt certain he'd attend one of the gigs. Andrew's missing-person posters were displayed at the events, including at a meet and greet with the band's guitarist, Mick Thompson.
在2007年9月14日那个周末参加过伦敦任何音乐会的人站出来，提供他们可能拍摄的任何照片或视频，以便超级识别者可以扫描其中是否有长得像安德鲁的人。2020年初，戈斯登一家收到消息，安德鲁最喜欢的乐队Slipknot正在英国巡演。如果安德鲁还活着并且是自愿生活的，他的家人确信他会参加其中一场演出。安德鲁的失踪人口海报在活动现场展示，包括在与乐队吉他手米克·汤普森的见面会上。
No new leads were generated, but the ongoing search efforts continued to catch the attention of the public who remained gripped by the case 13 years later. Andrew Gossden's disappearance remained a hot topic for online sleuths, each with their own theory as to what had happened. Every possibility had been considered, from Andrew falling victim to a serial killer, to him traveling to London to buy the latest PlayStation portable before an incident occurred. Then, in January 2022, a story appeared in the news that no one saw coming. South Yorkshire Police confirmed that on Wednesday, December 8, 2021, an arrest had been made in relation to the Andrew Gosden case. Two unnamed men aged 38 and 45 had been taken into custody on suspicion of kidnapping and human trafficking.
没有产生新的线索，但持续的搜索工作继续引起公众的关注，13年后他们仍然被这个案件所吸引。安德鲁·戈斯登的失踪仍然是在线侦探的热门话题，每个人都有自己关于发生了什么的理论。每一种可能性都被考虑过，从安德鲁成为连环杀手的受害者，到他去伦敦购买最新的PlayStation便携式游戏机，然后发生了意外。然后，在2022年1月，新闻中出现了一个没有人预料到的故事。南约克郡警方证实，2021年12月8日星期三，与安德鲁·戈斯登案有关的一人被捕。两名分别为38岁和45岁的未具名男子因涉嫌绑架和人口贩运被拘留。
The order of the two was also arrested for possessing indecent images of children. Police seized a number of electronic devices from the pair, but they said that a comprehensive review of the devices could take up to a year. Both men were therefore released while the enquiries continued. Police refused to disclose any further details, telling the media. Our priority at this time is supporting Andrew's family while we work through this new line of inquiry. We are in close contact with them, and they ask that their privacy is respected as our investigation continues. Almost two years passed before any sort of update.
其中年长的一位还因持有儿童淫秽图像而被捕。警方从两人手中查获了多台电子设备，但他们表示，对这些设备的全面审查可能需要长达一年的时间。因此，两名男子在调查继续期间被释放。警方拒绝透露任何进一步的细节，告诉媒体。我们目前的首要任务是在我们处理这一新调查方向的同时支持安德鲁的家人。我们与他们保持密切联系，他们要求在我们的调查继续期间尊重他们的隐私。近两年过去了，没有任何更新。
In late September 2023, South Yorkshire police announced that the two unnamed suspects in the Andrew Gosden case had been eliminated from their investigation. A spokesperson said they were confident the two men played no part, adding, the investigation remains open and active, and we would urge anyone with information to come forward. Kevin Gossden told the ThinAir podcast that if his son's disappearance has taught him anything, it's that a child can have the most secure and comfortable life, and still think the grass might be greener on the other side. He is now an ambassador for the charity Missing People, educating young people about how
2023年9月下旬，南约克郡警方宣布，安德鲁·戈斯登案中的两名未具名嫌疑人已被排除在调查之外。一位发言人表示，他们确信这两名男子没有参与其中，并补充说，调查仍然开放且活跃，我们敦促任何有信息的人站出来。凯文·戈斯登告诉ThinAir播客，如果他儿子的失踪教会了他什么，那就是一个孩子可以拥有最安全、最舒适的生活，却仍然认为草地可能在另一边更绿。他现在是慈善机构“失踪人口”的大使，教育年轻人如何
to stay safe if they are thinking about running away from home, or what to do if they already have and want to return. safe if they are thinking about running away from home or what to do if they already have and want to return. Kevin told Woman's own magazine, I hate the idea that Andrew might have had a problem he felt he couldn't tell me. That's why I implore all parents, talk to your children. Let them know they can tell you anything, and tell them if they ever consider running away or make a foolish decision, there are people who can give them the proper
在考虑离家出走时保持安全，或者如果他们已经离家出走并想回来该怎么办。凯文告诉《Woman's Own》杂志，我讨厌安德鲁可能遇到了他觉得无法告诉我的问题的想法。这就是为什么我恳求所有的父母，与你们的孩子交谈。让他们知道他们可以告诉你任何事情，并告诉他们，如果他们曾经考虑离家出走或做出愚蠢的决定，有人可以给他们提供适当的
support they need. Although Andrews Bank account hasn't been touched since he's final with the draw or on September 14, 2007, his family continues to top it up just in case. His room has since been repainted and decorated, but his presence is still strong. His favorite t-shirts are still sitting in a drawer, and he's prized a gem collection displayed on a shelf. The gostins have never changed their locks, just in case. July 10, 2023 marked what would have been Andrew's 30th birthday. He had now been missing for longer than he was around.
他们需要的支持。虽然安德鲁的银行账户自2007年9月14日他最后一次取款以来就没有被动过，但他的家人继续往里面存钱以防万一。他的房间后来被重新粉刷和装饰，但他的存在感依然强烈。他最喜欢的T恤仍然放在抽屉里，他珍贵的宝石收藏陈列在架子上。戈斯登一家从未更换过锁，以防万一。2023年7月10日是安德鲁本应30岁的生日。他失踪的时间现在已经比他存在的时间还要长了。
Throughout these years, Kevin Gostin continued to nurture the acorns that he helped Andrew plant when his son was just 10 years old. Just as Andrew predicted, several of the acorns sprouted and grew into miniature oak trees. Kevin gradually replanted them over the years, keeping one in his own back garden. By Andrew's 30th birthday, the oak tree stood at 6 feet tall and had sprouted acorns of its own. On his blog, Kevin wrote, As Andrew's oak tree bears the fruit of the acorn, we hope that awareness of his case bears the fruit that others are helped to find positive solutions in their lives, and
在这些年里，凯文·戈斯登继续培育他在儿子只有10岁时帮助安德鲁种下的橡子。正如安德鲁预测的那样，几颗橡子发芽并长成了微型橡树。凯文多年来逐渐将它们重新种植，并在自己的后花园里保留了一棵。到安德鲁30岁生日时，那棵橡树已经长到了6英尺高，并长出了自己的橡子。凯文在他的博客上写道，随着安德鲁的橡树结出橡子的果实，我们希望他案件的知名度能结出果实，帮助其他人找到他们生活中的积极解决方案，并且
that other families are spared the pain that too many of us live with, every day. In the 16 years since Andrew Gossden uncharacteristically caught the train to London and mysteriously went missing, no evidence has ever emerged to indicate whether he is alive or dead, and none of the belongings he left home with have ever been found. Kevin Gossden finds comfort in the fact that one of his last memories with Andrew was a happy one. The night before Andrew went missing, the father and son did the dishes together after dinner. As they stood in the kitchen with details in hand, Kevin gave Andrew a quick hug and told him,
其他家庭能免受我们太多人每天所承受的痛苦。在安德鲁·戈斯登反常地乘火车去伦敦并神秘失踪的16年里，没有任何证据表明他是死是活，他离家时带走的任何物品也从未被发现。凯文·戈斯登从他与安德鲁最后的记忆之一是快乐的这一事实中找到了安慰。安德鲁失踪的前一天晚上，父子俩在晚饭后一起洗碗。当他们手里拿着餐具站在厨房里时，凯文给了安德鲁一个快速的拥抱并告诉他，
I love you. As Kevin wrote on his blog, I am glad that he's one of the last things I have said to him. Andrew is never far from his parents' minds. Racked with ambiguous loss, Kevin ashamedly admitted to the Sun that he sometimes felt envious of parents whose children had been murdered, because at least they had closure. He described the experience of not knowing as an endless cycle of horror, explaining, The pain is like when you have a little kid and you turn your back for two seconds and they vanish, but then you find them again.
我爱你。正如凯文在他的博客上所写，我很高兴这是我对他说的最后几句话之一。安德鲁从未远离他父母的心。凯文因这种模棱两可的失踪而备受折磨，他羞愧地向《太阳报》承认，他有时会羡慕那些孩子被谋杀的父母，因为至少他们有了了结。他描述了这种不知道的经历是一个无尽的恐怖循环，解释说，这种痛苦就像当你有一个小孩，你转过身两秒钟他们就消失了，但随后你又找到了他们。
That horrible panic-stricken gut-wrenching feeling you have in that moment goes on and on and on forever for us. Glenus once described it as someone coming up to you and sticking a knife in your guts. Normally it would hurt, but the knife would be removed and the wound would be stitched up and heal after a period of time. With this, someone has stuck the knife in, but you have to walk around with it and it's always there, always hurting, and getting twisted frequently and regularly. Головей. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
那种在那一刻你所感受到的可怕的、惊慌失措的、撕心裂肺的感觉，对我们来说永远持续下去。格莱尼斯曾将其描述为有人走到你面前，把刀插进你的肚子。通常这会很痛，但刀会被拔出来，伤口会被缝合，并在一段时间后愈合。而对于这件事，有人把刀插了进去，但你必须带着它四处走动，它总是存在，总是疼痛，并且经常且有规律地被扭动。目前还没有关于这一集的评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。